Speaker 1: Also, please join for free here.
I'm not selling anything.
Often I am selling things.
In this case I'm not.
There are almost 31000 of our viewers and
listeners currently subscribe to The David
Pakman Show sub Reddit.
It's free.
It's moderated.
It's a great central place to discuss the
issues talked about on the show and other
issues important to you.
You can find it at David Pakman Dotcom Reddit.
One user and I spotted this this morning asked,
Should Tucker Carlson bid platformed?
Of course not by the government, but by Fox
News.
Not that they would ever do such a thing.
I know this sub Reddit has many free speech
absolutists, but where do we draw the line?
Tucker is literally spreading extremely dangerous
anti vaccine propaganda that will lead to
the death of his own audience.
You know what's funny is the Fox News like
like any of these networks.
For the most part, Fox News is amoral.
Fox News is concerned with what revenue does
Tucker's program bring in?
What prestige does Tucker's program provide?
Fox News.
What access does Tucker's program give us
to people in positions of power?
Now, on the first question about the profitability
of Tucker Carlson on Fox News, it's actually
probably not as high as some people think
because increasingly Tucker's advertisers
have abandoned him.
And if you watch the show on broadcast TV,
which I never do, but I've gotten reports
about the ads on it, it's increasingly like
very non prestigious brands and advertisers.
So to me, it seems as though the Tucker Carlson
program has good ratings, gives Fox News attention
and and sort of free publicity because others
talk about the crazy things Tucker is saying.
I don't know how profitable the program actually
is for FOX News, but the point here is Fox
News would only consider getting rid of Tucker
Carlson if it provided a net negative to Fox
News.
They don't care about the dangerous anti vaccine
propaganda that Tucker Carlson is spreading
unless and that's why this post is clever.
If his own audience starts to die such that
nobody's left alive to walk the show, to watch
the show, they all of a sudden would care.
You know, while on some level it's probably
true that the behavior Tucker encourages will
lead to some deaths, I don't think it'll be
enough to really impact Tucker Carlson's audience.
So I have no expectation that Fox News is
going to do anything about Tucker Carlson's
program.
It's been on for years.
It does well from the standpoint of ratings.
And Fox News, quite frankly, doesn't really
care what he says, as long as it doesn't become
a real problem for them, either furthering
the financial issues or in some other way.
So I my view would be on this.
Rather than imposing that a network fire,
Tucker, or whatever the ideal mechanism would
be, people realize that it's a completely
vapid show.
It's not news.
It's just kind of like weird entertainment
for some people and that they just should
tune out and then it'll naturally resolve
itself.
I mean, maybe at some point if nobody's watching,
Fox News will say, I guess we're wrapping
the show.
I would rather it come from the bottom up
than the top down.
And I won't I have no expectation that we're
going to see anything from the top down from
Fox News.
They just don't seem to care.
Another user on the Reddit asked a very good
question, which is what happened to the Noam
Chomsky interview?
David has been teasing it for a while, but
it just never happened.
Yeah.
You know, back in early March and I said when
I teased it, I said, I'm running a risk here.
A lot of people in the audience don't realize
how frequently interviews get rescheduled
and postponed or even canceled because it
was exciting.
I announced in early March, were scheduled
to have Noam Chomsky on later that month.
I think it was going to be March in the second
half of March.
And people were very excited.
But unfortunately, it did get rescheduled
and it was actually rescheduled to next week.
And unfortunately, that has now been rescheduled
into early June.
This is very common, particularly the more
well-known the guest is, the more common this
is.
There are interviews that we've had four or
five even reschedules on.
So I'm hoping it'll happen soon.
And so, you know, it was interesting to me
and I knew the audience would find it interesting.
So I took the risk of mentioning this was
scheduled.
Maybe I just shouldn't have said anything
at all.
Nobody would be asking about it.
And then hopefully in early June, there would
just be an interview with Noam Chomsky.
But it is on the calendar for the first few
days of June and hopefully, hopefully it will
actually happen.
Joined the discussion on the sub.
Read it at David Pakman dot com slash R.E.D..
Dite t